now we have some very special people we
have trustees of the college and it is
something to become a trustee it means
that you are in fact in a fiduciary
responsibility not just with all those
who have gone before and those who are
there now but for generations into the
future
you were saying you hold that most
precious college in your hands and I
want to recognize our trustees hazel
hair Greg and Dana Schuler mark Johnson
and trustee emeritus mr. and mrs. Frank
vide please stand all please trustees
now I also have to ask Hillsdale has got
a giant his name is Jared Bell dear
would you stand up Jared please I want
people to meet the giant he is now a
Arizona Cardinal but the better half
Morgan Valdez there would you stand up
Morgan the volleyball player now I saw
Jared and I gave him a hard time I am a
long-suffering Cleveland Browns fan I
went to every home game from 1965 to
1974 I bought the tickets when they came
back after they were ripped out of our
city and returned in 1999 until I've had
season tickets from 1999 asked Jared why
didn't sign with the Browns he said
there's a guy named Joe Thomas now Joe
is in fact a seven-time Pro Bowler but
we do have a right tackle Mitch Schwartz
who needs to move inside Jared so I'm a
little disappointed but if you'll pledge
us your child to the Browns that's all I
care about
all right good eye dr. Arnn was telling
me that jared is not only a wonderful
example of the combination of athletics
and scholarship that comes out of
Hillsdale but also of loyalty to the
college and it has made part of his good
fortune the good fortune of Hillsdale I
salute you for that that's really a
remarkable thing and thank you
my friends at 960 am the patriot and at
Cambridge Wealth Management helped make
this event possible and thank you to you
all for doing so I love my station here
in town and I want you to know for the
benefit of those of you who are shy this
program is recorded for an audio CD of
it afterwards and dr. Arnn will say some
things that are memorable you just have
to ask a staff member at the
registration table I'll also tell you
that at the back you will be able to
find free copies of dr. arns book the
founders key you'll also find that this
this presentation will be online and
posted very very soon many college
materials are at the bat and they are
free and I would like you to not only
take them for yourselves but for people
who ought to be involved in the cause
and I'll be telling about the cause in
just a moment please spread the word
spread the word not just about dr. Arnn
and the founders key and about Hillsdale
but about the fact that people who are
concerned about the future of the
country can find a real tangible way to
be involved in it I tell people you've
been given ten fingers to keep track of
ten things you've got to have in your
life a church and a parachurch
organization you've got to have in your
life at least to organize a to colleges
one of which not your own that you are
supporting and one veteran's
organization and at least five
candidates and if you do not have
something for each one of those fingers
you are not doing your job one of those
fingers a lot of you helped us I saw
Kathy and judge Herradura and a lot of
you helped us elected Ducey and you have
a terrific governor in the state of
Arizona so that was one of those five
and you've got great congressman and
you've got a great budget you've got a
great future and I'll be back next week
at the Chamber of Commerce to sit down
with another great governor Scott Walker
but I wanted to begin
oh you know largely because of Larry our
and my profile has been rising a little
bit every time I see Larry he says we've
got to make you more famous I said
that's not hard to do if you start from
a position of very low but Larry works
at it very hard and he goes around so
the last week I was on Meet the Press I
was on the cover of national journal I
was profiled in The Huffington Post it
was announced that I was going to be a
questioner at one of the presidential
debates and people asked me how did that
happen
and I very candidly tell them I believe
that that happened because Larry aren't
committed three years ago to something
called the Hillsdale dialogues now I
don't know if you listen to them at the
last radio or hour of the week and it's
a good rule of thumb that if you hang
around smart people folks will get
confused and think you're smart even
when you ask a lot of dumb questions and
I ask a lot of dumb questions on the
Hillsdale dialogues but they are all
available online and they are now 100
plus hours of conversation between dr.
Arnn and myself and the colleagues that
he has and they are wonderful colleagues
Paul ray and Steven Smith and Tom wess I
could name a dozen of them who have come
forward and we began with Homer and last
week we were doing Nietzsche which was a
real happy hour and everything in
between and now we are going deep into
the Constitution we're gonna be talking
a little bit about that tonight but I
view that little aspect of Hillsdale
it's just one of the things that the
college does that goes so far beyond the
college for a hundred and seventy years
that has been what I call the lantern of
the north and I got that when I was in
Scotland a few years ago I went to Elgin
and Elgon is way north up in Scotland
and in fact they had a Cathedral that
they called the lantern of the North
sounds pretty good right until they
figured out that the Vikings could see
it and they came and burn it down but I
liked that title of the lantern of the
north because they always kept the fire
burning and Mariners could find true
north and they could find Scotland by
finding the lantern of the north until
the Vikings actually looted it Hillsdale
for a hundred and seventy years has been
the lantern of the north of America it's
up near our North Coast it has stood for
the same thing since before its founding
it has been led by great men it has been
led by great people and it has always
been led by the principle that the
American Constitution represents an
extraordinary moment in time and space
that is to be replicated and to be
honored and to be understood and if
possible protected and that's their
mission that's why I'm so in love with
the colleges they keep doing it and they
keep doing it they keep doing it every
single Hillsdale student studies the
Constitution they study Western
civilization they study the American
Constitution they study how it is that
we got here we are all arrived here by a
thousand different stories and I saw a
story the other night in the movie
theater called 71 it's the story of
ulster during the Troubles and it's a
terrible terrible movie it's absolutely
riveting but you wonder how is it that
that great British Empire was so torn
asunder and Ulster that it never
happened here and it happened that we
were prepared the sectarian violence and
that we were spared that disunity
because of those genius that gathered in
Philadelphia in 1787 and before that
that gathered in Philadelphia in 1776
and another genius who came along in
1860 and restored the electric cord that
binds us all in dr. Aaron will be
talking about that in a little bit but
that is always as Ronald Reagan said one
generation from being lost yesterday it
was this close to being lost in Israel
this close and
and it wasn't and I like to think it
wasn't I'm gonna embarrass iron a little
bit here in fact I'd like to embarrass
aren't a lot if I could tonight but
because he does that routinely to me on
the radio a routinely not a week goes by
but I'm gonna embarrass him in a good
way I think Bibi Netanyahu owes his
election to Larry Arndt and I have an
argument why because two weeks ago a
letter was circulated and signed by a
young man named Tom cotton who was an
extraordinary American and that letter
crystallized for this week a key issue
as to how the Constitution operates with
regards to foreign agreements with
dictators and that letter crystallized a
great reaction on the left and they
bared their teeth they showed their
fangs they were hysterical with anger at
Tom cotton now here's something you may
not know before Larry iron came to
Hillsdale he was the president of the
Claremont Institute the Claremont
Institute runs a tremendous program
called the Publius fellows and the
Publius fellows bring out young people
young men and women eighteen nineteen
twenty and they fill up their head with
all these dangerous ideas that occurred
around Philadelphia in 1776 and 1777 and
1789 and then they send them off to go
back to places like Harvard and Harvard
Law School where cotton managed to get
through without too much damage being
done days understanding a constitution
and they prepare them for public life
and they prepare them for service so Tom
cotton didn't just get out of Harvard
Law School and go to work in the big law
firm or the DC Circuit or all those
other wonderful things he did he got out
and he said I will go into the military
because I understand it's my duty to do
so and I will go provided that you do
not make me a lawyer now I have great
admiration for lawyers in the military I
know some of them who've served in
harm's way and one of them just got back
to the Assistant United States
Attorney's Office that he left a year
ago and he was outside the wire every
day at Camp Bondsteel so I got nothing
against lawyers but being a ranger is
different from being a lawyer in the
military and Tom cotton went and he was
a ranger
and then he came back and he sent a
letter up to some other Arne Betty's at
power line and para line made the
country aware of Tom cotton and Tom
cotton then got the idea that he'd come
back to DC after he'd done his service
as a ranger and he'd run for Congress
with a lot of people scoffed at that and
he talked to Larry art about that Larry
Ahrens said you're ready for Congress go
for Congress guy named Lincoln tried it
and so he ran anyone against the odds
and then a couple of years went by less
than two years went by and he took a
look at the fact that the country's in
trouble and he said I'm going to take on
a sitting senator who is a legatee
senator meaning his last name is Pryor
and you don't beat priors in Arkansas
and he consulted again and I'll
embarrass Larry again he didn't call me
didn't call the power line guys called
Larry he talked about whether or not
that was a good idea to do
and Larry Orrin I don't know what his
advice was all I know is that he's been
consulting with Tom cotton every step of
the way and Tom cotton would be one of
the first people to say what he's
learned about the framing and what went
into that letter that letter that stood
for first principle the Constitution's
or things that he learned from Larry
Aron and from Hillsdale College and from
the Publius fellowship
so tonight in this room because you
support this college you are directly
connected and I mean directly connected
to the result in Israel yesterday that
sent a chilling message to the mullahs
of Teheran who would terrorize the world
thank you for doing that thank you for
supporting this college now if you are
not already receiving in Primus where
have you been now every week I say in
Primus is free and I want you to sign up
for it I want you to sign up everybody
in your family for it and I want to spin
I want the message to spread if
everybody does that three times the
exponential impact event you find three
people and they sign up three people and
they sign up three people
Hillsdale can prosper and grow and in
its mission become absolutely more
influential I'm going to close by
turning this over to Larry and then
we're going to talk by telling you about
just two other senators one of them's
named Ted Cruz who you may have heard a
little bit about as well Aaron tells me
last week he went to an event where Cruz
was talking about Hillsdale College and
the commencement address that he gave
there and the impact it's having on the
country and I don't doubt that for a
second because Ted has always said that
to me when he's in California and a
third Senator Mike Lee Mike Lee called
me up last week I was up at a at a
bastion of wrongheadedness Stanford at a
little fortress within Stanford of
right-handedness the Hoover Institution
and my phone rang and it was Mike Lee
and Mike Lee wanted me to do a
fundraiser for him now I typically I've
only done one fundraiser because it's a
pain in the neck right I'll go to him
and I'll write checks but to organize
the pain in the neck Mike Lee asked me
if I'd do a fundraiser for him and I
said instantly you betcha I'll do it
because you are a friend of Larry Arne
of Hillsdale College and you go to the
Kirby Center and that means you're
serious about your job so as you sit
here tonight and we're talking about the
college and what the college does and
the crisis understand that the crisis is
real but so are the reinforcements
and they're coming out of this room and
they're coming out of Hillsdale College
and they're coming out of the people
that you support everyday by being a
supporter of this whether it's a Jarod
whether it's the trustees whether it's
the parents whether it's the alum you've
built a great thing and it's something
about what you ought to be proud and you
ought to tell people so without further
ado I would like to introduce the
president this institution to talk about
a little bit of where we find ourselves
and then I'm going to subject him to
rigorous cross-examination dr. Larry our
thank you it's always better if that
happens before you say anything okay can
everybody hear me it slightly come to
site that I'm a terrible public speaker
and I have a reputation people tell me
of being pretty good at it but that's
because people can't hear and so if at
any point you can't hear hold up your
hand and I will mumble
now I'm gonna thirty minutes ago so
uhyou it has been a friend of mine for
it's got to be close to 25 years now
before he was famous and I I do have a
purpose a valid purpose to make him more
famous and the reason is he's not very
smart but he's smarter than most people
on the radio and it's good for the
country if he does well 30 and the thing
about dealing with him and it's 25 years
now I've been dealing with him is you
never have the least idea what's about
to happen and so this is like our event
right here you people are all here
tonight is the guest of Hillsdale
College which I happen to be you know I
run the dang place but now the plan is
not what I was told so I'm to talk to
you for a minute and I didn't know that
and I'm gonna do that in a minute I'm
gonna tell you what I'm gonna say cuz
I'm just gonna say a few things I'm
gonna make fun of you and explain
something about why he's good I'm gonna
tell you something about Tom cotton
something about Netanyahu and then I'm
going to tell you one thing about the
state of the Republic as it relates to
education and that's all I'm gonna do
but before I did that I I wanted I want
you to know I'm gonna tell you somethin
bout Jared veld here so Jared and his
wife Morgan and his brother Aaron are
graduates of Hillsdale College and that
means in the case of Jared I didn't know
him when he was small he never was
he and his brother are exactly one foot
different in height the brother played
point guard on the basketball team
Jared played the whole left side of our
offensive line and the main thing in
Morgan you know who's I'd say 80% is
smart as Jared and Aaron put together
she's great with child by the way and
and they're both smart they're both very
good students
Jared again I think it's not legal well
I I don't take money from the government
it is legal let me tell you about their
student records so Aaron Aaron the
lawyer was near top of his class and
Jared was it'd be terrible for me to say
his grade point average but it was three
point four and at Hillsdale College
that's hard right biology said you want
to be a medical doctor you'd have to
work in a very large hospital and what I
know about him is I know them all three
and I you know and I'm very I'm very
proud of Jared Jared but not so much
because he's one of the best players in
the NFL I am proud about that I like
football but I like what he is he's a
very fine young man and I'm gonna ask
him to come up and say something to you
for just a minute
all right so I am really am getting up
here and saying something all right
excellent I just want to say thanks to
Hillsdale for for everything that it's
taught me my family just you know
tremendous you know virtue and integrity
that it instills in you and I think
that's one of the reasons that I've been
able to have success in the NFL just all
the all the things that you learn about
Hillsdale I mean you can't go to
Hillsdale without signing an honor code
and that's something that's pretty
unique to Hillsdale and you know when I
was there they you know some people were
kind of you know especially the younger
students were like when we had a sign an
honor code to go here and really they
should ask themself that question about
ten years down the road after they have
their degree and when they're actually
out in their profession because they'll
look back and know why they did and know
what they're a part of and you know the
great thing that they did and getting a
degree from Hillsdale and what that
Hillsdale degree is doing for them so I
just wanted to say thanks for everyone
supporting the college I'm very proud to
be an alum and I'm proud to be married
to an alum maybe have a future alum I'm
not sure the size of the babies telling
me that it might be tough to convince
convince them to go Division two but I
don't know anyway I I want to say thanks
to dr. Arnn
and thanks to Hillsdale College thanks
for all of you coming out
I am exactly the height of Winston
Churchill so I want to tell you a story
about Jared
Jared's sweet he's a sweet boy
and he's a little nerdy too and so we
had some really big victories when he
played football for us and it was
because he would block the entire right
side of the defensive line and when you
know we play good sports in our college
we were very good at it but the weird
thing about it is so in the year that
Jared graduated a boy graduated who
graduated from Yale Law School at the
top of his class and has been a supreme
court clerk and is one of the most
important young lawyers in America today
and that boy is rocket scientist smart
right Aaron is very smart and half the
time in their college careers Jared and
that boy and every other kid at
Hillsdale College were taking the same
classes because half the classes are the
same for every kid in the college and
that means Jared has read Herodotus and
Thucydides and Plato and Aristotle and
he studied chemistry and physics and
biology and math and he studied the
history of Western civilization as every
kid does right and
every kid at Hillsdale does that and so
for and when he was at the other place
where he used to coach I used to say in
our athletic department that the
athletic program at Hillsdale College
has been appointed by God to make the
Oakland Raiders respectable I think they
were puzzled like he would look at the
signs and he could read them so thank
you Hugh for us to live we have to reach
a lot of people you know the only person
like when Hugh hosts one of these events
which he we try to get him to do every
year he's the only one who ever suggests
Joe to give us any money I don't bring
it up if you want to give us money well
it must have you many of you will at
least will but to get that to happen cuz
you know if you do give money it'll
because you love the same thing we do
right and the generosity is your virtue
not mine and and so we have to tell a
lot of people what we do to find the
thousand people who come tonight and
like what we do and learn about it
that's how the college works and so we
need a way to reach a lot of people and
Hugh is the best single person to do
that with because I'll say it once and
never again he's pretty smart and he's
pretty good
I've been corresponding with Tom cotton
this week and I email to him and told
him that I liked what he did I wear my
wife and I happen to know his wife very
well and had known him since he was in
undergraduate school and he's a very
great man he's really gonna be something
he is something right now
and it's a pattern about him so he he
wants to establish that he's worthy
citizen of America in order to present
himself to his fellow citizens for
public office his way of doing that is
to expose himself to gunfire for months
he's like that he asked me to lobby the
military I know generals and a few to
make sure he didn't get Judge Advocate
General then he wants to and see I
looked it up this week and sent it to
him he didn't ask me to but I thought I
would because he's busy this tradition
the modern there's an old tradition and
a modern tradition of bipartisan foreign
policy and the modern tradition of
bipartisan foreign policy starts with
the relationship between three people to
Harry Truman Dean Acheson and Arthur
Vandenberg a Republican senator and they
worked out a deal in the aftermath of
the Second World War and this deal gave
rise to America's leadership in the
world they did the Marshall Plan and
they did the Truman Doctrine which save
specifically Greece and Turkey and saved
their for NATO and saved their for the
united effort to oppose the Soviet Union
and those three guys really worked that
out together and the deal that they made
which is very well recorded it's easy to
look up in in history and particularly
you can read each a sentence book
president at the creation the deal they
made was we have separate jobs we in the
Congress and the executive branch and we
don't have the power to give up those
jobs and we don't have the power to do
each
there's jobs but we do need to present a
united front and so here's what we're
going to do an anxious and in particular
thought this up takes pride in the fact
that he did in his book we're gonna talk
to you all the time about what we do and
we're going to not make any agreement
with anybody that we don't discuss with
you in advance and then present to you
for debate is a formal treaty and see by
the way that doesn't just involve the
Congress then in the process that
involves every one of us see because you
learned from Winston Churchill I have
learned from Winston Churchill that he
thought that the activity of debate in
the House of Commons is the way we all
get to participate and watch what the
government does because when you debate
with the opposition you have to state
your reasons and then it becomes
possible for reason to govern right and
so the deal they worked out with
vandenberg is we're gonna talk to you in
advance we're gonna give you a chance to
debate and we're gonna compromise with
you and we're gonna get it as much of
that done as possible before we tell
anybody in the outside world so now this
is the agreement the Tom cotton is
accused of breaking did he
because here's the point Obama's
response from his own lips was and and
from his agents who talked to the press
both was that of course the Congress is
not going to be able to overturn this
because a whole bunch of nations are
going to agree to it in other words it
is his valid purpose to present the
legislative representatives of the
American people with a fait accompli and
that is a scorn of secretary separation
of powers which James Madison says is
the central protection that we have
after the fact that we get to elect them
so the plan is
that's something fundamental going on
isn't it I mean it's not just is it by
the you should go read Tom Cotton's
maiden speech given two or three nights
ago you can find it on c-span it was a
tour de force is very powerful I was
privileged to read bits of it while he
was writing it and he actually asked me
a question about Winston Churchill and I
answered it and darned if I didn't get
it wrong and he got it right I'm annoyed
with the boy
but but but you see this question of the
foreign policy question of whether it's
a good idea what are we gonna do about
Iraq Iran what are they going to be
going to do if they get nuclear weapons
what if they build a great Empire and
now there's three or four and we're one
let's say four with Russia and China and
the in the Muslim world
what's that world gonna be like to live
in that's that's very serious stuff
right but it actually is the second most
serious stuff because the most serious
stuff is how we're going to govern
ourselves is it a fact that we have the
right in the laws of nature and of
nature's God effectively to consent to
the government over us is it a fact that
there were those who work in the
government are obliged to work hard to
make that consent possible to us to our
convenience you know there are three
trustees of the college here tonight and
I ask you they stood up you can you know
they are mark Johnson and Greg Schuler
and Frank Veidt you can ask them after
this I run the college and I do run it
very much and I'm very powerful runner
of it asked them if I don't make it
plain what I'm doing was time for them
to make a decision because it's my job
it also by the way incidentally makes me
stronger because if I have to fight
somebody and
sometimes then I'm able to look at them
and say you know there's a whole bunch
of us you're gonna have to quarrel with
and you couldn't even beat me by myself
I have said that to people sometimes and
so that's the times we live in and my
real point that I want to make is just a
simple one why has this happened what's
going on in the world so I've learned
something teaching in college I'll say
this to all you young ones the reason I
tell you and I tell you the ones who
might come there to here tonight who are
planning to come that I've met they're
probably others I always said the same
thing to him I say you have to
understand it's hell it's real cold air
and the town is remote and boring and
we've had five people get a four point
in 25 years you know you should really
start to sit to both them tonight I said
you should great think about going
somewhere else
and you know they all you know cuz
they're young right and I'm this old man
talking to them that way why do I do
that
because I've learned something from them
I don't teach them they learn the things
I know there are two things that I know
as much about is anybody alive and
there's a third that I have a serious
academic knowledge of and I'm very
qualified to teach those things and I
love those things I've given my life to
them
I studied them with the best teachers in
the world both of them have died in the
last few months I used to think that it
was because of those teachers that I
know what I know but then I started
teaching myself and I found that if I
tried to do too much for them they were
just young and I've started to form a
picture of the human soul from their
faces in class they have the gift to
know in them but they have to struggle
to know just like I did I made choices
to know what I know I gave myself to it
for a long time every close friend in
the world I've got Tom cotton is one
Hugh Hewitt is one they all love the
same things I love and that means they
own it as much as I own it now today
when we talk about education we forget
that sacred fact that is apparent in the
soul of every human being and we think
that there's an entitlement to education
and we think that we can run the schools
better to make people better factors of
production it's dehumanizing right now
in America everywhere all over here
every public school in the land is
taking February and March off to cram
for a bunch of standardized tests and
they're written by a bunch of
bureaucrats who are always inventing
something new whereas by the way
you know Plato's Republic it's been a
great book for nearly 2,500 years so
something has arisen that makes the
people in power want to treat us as
tools and that and not Iraq is the
crisis of the age Iran sorry
and we have to defend ourselves against
Iran and we have to do that urgently in
my opinion but I will also say that if
we fix that problem that we have
abandoned the laws of nature and of
nature's God in America if we fix that
problem Iran and everybody like them
will quake before us
because freedom and justice are the
strongest forces on earth nobody expects
the Spanish Inquisition let's start with
something you do a lot of at the college
Larry are you produce a lot of high
school teachers many of them are
employed here in Phoenix by great hearts
and other charter schools and you you
produce a lot for your own charter
schools and I think this is a very
important mission of the college what do
you think about that part of your
mission well of course it's precious to
me because the most important young
academic in America today Kathleen Arne
O'Toole is the head of one of our
charter schools in Austin Texas we have
eight charter schools now and we're
opening four more in August and the goal
is 50 right now there's about 4,000
students going to them everybody learns
Latin everybody wears uniforms everybody
signs an honor code there's one
operating in Savannah Georgia in the
inner-city school building where
Clarence Thomas went to school for two
years and the strategy you know
Hillsdale College is a two-part strategy
your presence here is a sign that we've
done pretty well and it's always against
the odds we're not as rich is the
richest and we don't have the federal
government to pay our need-based aid but
the point is we're trying to make it and
I invite by the way every single one of
you to come and visit come in September
and October if you're whining about the
weather and and I will you pick a week
when I'm in town they're known for in
advance and I go and eat in the dining
hall every day that I'm on campus and I
sit with the students and I'll take you
with me and you can see what happens
it's glorious
it's I just I tell you it's just very
beautiful now our job is to make that as
perfect as humanly it can be
and then the second part of the job is
to make that radiate everywhere that's
why this night that's why online courses
which by the way I learned two days ago
have now passed a million registrations
that that's why in Primus and that's why
these charter schools and the Y can be
summarized simply James Madison and
Thomas Jefferson toward the end of their
lives wrote some letters back and forth
about how to preserve the Republic and
they didn't say what you'd think you
know I wrote the Constitution we should
read that I wrote the Declaration of
Independence no we should read that we
should follow the precepts of my
presidential administration now mine
write that by the way that reminds you
of anybody in politics today they said
no we have to teach people to understand
the fundamental expressions that are
used in the making of America and so
these three kids I met tonight who are
coming to Hillsdale College you're going
to learn what is meant by the expression
the laws of nature and of nature's God
and you're going to be able to explain
those laws against intelligent
opposition which we are going to provide
to you and that is the way to fix the
heart and mind of the country that's why
that's important
second question by the way I was at
Larry's invited me to college
occasionally he invites me in January
and he invited me to Arizona when it was
raining
estimate of where I am and Larry he
invited you to come in the fall I come
in January if he started with if he
stopped whining about the weather I'll
let him come in the fall well when I
came in in January a young intern had
worked for me for the summer sat down
and asked him a trick question about
Hagel so I actually saw this and I saw
the track team become involved in a
conversation about Hagel and whether or
not Hagel thought the perfect state
involved coercion or some such thing I
can't remember what it was and it wasn't
unusual that is in fact usual and it's
actually pleasant as well well we've you
know you have to understand about a
college nobody knows what a college is
anymore first of all the word college
means partnership it's something a bunch
of people do together now that means
they have to agree on the purpose that
that means not diversity the word
University which is almost as old as the
word college that means many things
turning around one thing whereas the
word diversity their cognate it's
they're both they're both from Latin
that means many things turning around
more than one thing right so if you ever
hear anybody saying you will that the
purpose of University X is diversity
you can mark that person down for
illiterate
so it's just true but but so once you
agree on what you're gonna get done like
we want to understand the best things
there are to understand and they are
naturally interesting to everyone
everybody wants to know you know like
say to somebody what is God well the
first thing I'll do is they'll dismiss
that is an idea that's just whatever
anybody thinks right and then when you
introduce them to the fact that if
that's true that means that there isn't
any God
they've taken a position now see then
all of a sudden you're thinking about it
and theology is your stubborn subject
people love that so once you agree
that's what you're going to do then the
question is what's the truth of it
there's where the diversity part comes
in because academic institutions proceed
by evidence and argument and proof and
that means that Hillsdale College
everything is an argument and it has to
be and you know when you're one of the
teachers when the student says something
the more true it is the more you have to
disagree with it now I want to return to
Mike Lee and the conversation I had he
said when I brought you up that you were
a mentor of his I hope not in the
department of socks but not going to win
reelection if that's the case but but
what is this Kirby Center why are you
doing it why have you planted your flag
on Capitol Hill
why should this audience know about that
well that thank you the so Mike Lee is a
friend of mine he get we my wife and I
we don't own a house in Hillsdale we
live we're tenants of the college and so
we bought a little house close to the
Carver Center in Capitol Hill and we
bought it so that I didn't have to stay
on hotels on Capitol Hill all the time
which er if you're like me you're gone a
lot and you get tired of that but also
we bought it so we could have people
over for dinner who Mike Lee anybody and
see our lobbying efforts are confined
and two people who are really smart and
willing to learn and I don't care how
powerful they are
Lee happens to be very powerful and
cotton is becoming powerful but why is
that those guys friends of mine
they're just delightful people and they
learn a lot so in that correspondence
between Madison and Jefferson they're
talking in particular are they talking
generally what a citizen needs to know
but they're talking in particular what a
statesman needs to know and they don't
know these things these days I mean I
that one of the presidential candidates
I was taught he called me the other day
and I was doing the fun with him for 30
minutes and it was a very I'm not gonna
tell his name it would surprise you it's
a prominent one and it was a very
gratifying call and I didn't expect it
to be and he said I thought he was going
to say you know I'm really a
conservative and you should help me
because I have some credentials in that
world and it wasn't anything like that
he said you know I watched one of your
courses the other day that was great I
said thank you he said I have a
suggestion you should do a an online
course for prospective citizens I said
that's a great idea
so we're working on it and when we do it
you'll find out that person's name and
then he said I think there's something
you know a lot about he said describe to
me American values and I said well they
didn't use that term you know that's a
term for modern social science and it
places the emphasis on what do you think
and by the way all you freshmen to be
next year don't come and tell me your
opinion about anything I don't give a
crap about that
yeah here's some times in these meetings
somebody will say if I come to Hillsdale
will you respect my opinion now we say
yeah we don't care about that what we
want to know is what do you claim is the
truth right then we can answer the claim
and make our own claim right then we can
all learn we don't like answers one of
them tonight from one of the young women
who's coming next year we don't like the
answers that begin will to me you know
so I always say yeah I stop and say what
do I care about that you know so so the
point is we don't values that's what it
means I said they talked about
principles and then they talked about
character which is the thing you know
that comes from that word comes from a
Greek word that means to etch or engrave
the thing in us that makes us so when
hound dog over here behemoths bull
mastiff goes to the Oakland Raiders what
do they say what does the coach of the
Arizona Cardinals say about him and see
I know him better than they do
I've watched him grow up they say boy
that guy he's very motivated he's very
careful he has real integrity in other
words they're saying
Jared Bell dear has an excellent
character he won't lie to you if he
makes a commitment he'll keep it that's
what character means see what's the
American character I explained it on the
phone it took three minutes
he said gosh that wasn't beautiful he
said did you make that up and I said you
know sir if you want to hear the great
symphony you don't have to write one
somebody already did that
and he said but you carry that around
you and I said yes I do many at the
college do and he said I think that's
wonderful now you see that is the
specific kind of thing that man needs to
know and it will change the world if
they know that that's why Tom cotton is
like what he is
it's mean it scary it's by the way it's
always two things when I say to you
young ones who might coming next year
you have to be both willing and able I'm
making a statement about your intellect
and your character because you have to
give yourself to so tom has a really
excellent character he's a remarkable
man gosh he's he's quiet son of a gun
but he's very bold you know I mean this
stuff he did last week that was crazy
and great but also he knows because he
thinks you and I have been friends all
these years because every time we have a
conversation we're interested in the
same stuff and forever which brings me
to this we are if not on the occasion of
one hundred and fiftieth anniversary of
the deliverance of Lincoln's second
inaugural we are close to it why is that
a great speech well you have to put the
first and the second inaugurals together
do you do you know the speeches come and
read them tonight by the way it's a it's
like reading poetry do you know what to
peoria speeches it's 1858
I think Lincoln went away and put
together the history of slavery in the
Union and gave it at Peoria and I was
reading it in my study once 10 years ago
because a friend of mine published a
book about it and read it in 25 years
and my wife walked in the study and she
said hi and I said hi and then she said
are you crying and I said little bit and
she said why and I said dear it's really
crazy to say but I'm
the PSP and I just tell you it's so
generous and so wise and so great and
it's not as good as the first and second
in our girl the first inaugural is a
legal appeal about the nature of the
Union and it ends with the poem the the
legal argument is first of all two
people make a contract one can't break
it
that's secession right and you can't be
a strict constructionist and say that
only the words of the Constitution are
sovereign and then be a secessionist
because those words happen not to be in
there and and so he lays that out and he
says and remember the physical fact that
we cannot separate physically we can't
and if we if we break into two countries
your slaves are still going to run
across the border because they want to
get away and that's going to be a worse
problem than it is now and then he ends
by saying I am loath to close the hearth
fires of our land and the nd graves of
the Patriots we share in common right so
that's that one now the second inaugural
is short and the second inaugural is an
explanation of the failure of the appeal
in the first inaugural and it's a
religious poem he says I don't have a
lot to say he says it looks like the war
is gonna go okay he says the war is a
judgment on us because and see remember
remember the duty of anybody anyway like
I know some things and because of that
they own me I must do what they say I've
given my commitment to the
I carry them in my heart everybody I
work with is just like that it's a very
beautiful thing pretty hue and our
friends because of that right so we
Americans are like that because we have
a birthday and a document that gives the
reasons for what we are and it commands
us to do things that are very difficult
and we often fail and when we fail
grandly we have to pay for it so that's
what Lincoln says he says if every drop
of blood drawn by the lash during two
hundred years of the bondsman's
unrequited toil must now be paid repaid
was another drawn by the sword still it
will be said that the ways of the Lord
are righteous all together it is strange
that some men should pray to adjust God
to wring their bread from the sweat of
other men's faces woe to the world
because of offences and woe but if
offenses must need to come woe to them
by home it cometh now a farmer
uneducated from the frontier wrote those
words and saved this Union wrote them
himself it's one of the most beautiful
things that ever happened to the point
to remember when it looks desperate is
if that can happen any good thing can
happen and likely will
I have the advantage of having
interviewed Larry a few times and having
been in his seminars so I know it's best
stuff it's like what I am out with
Prager is a very bad man and and I
usually get him to tell his best story
but there's there's a bit of Churchill's
life that Larry talks about that I think
is useful at this time in the context of
Iran and it is that he participated in
the last cavalry charge of the British
Empire but in so doing learned a lesson
about where we were going that Larry
explicates and I think it's useful for
people to hear again and again and again
I never tire actually of hearing it I've
probably heard it six or seven times but
would you give them the setup and the
lesson and it's applicability so Winston
Churchill who was five foot seven and a
half inches tall was a very great man he
was like Lincoln and and remember
remember what they're like like I can
tell you stories about the greatest of
the Statesman and they're rare but when
you hear the story it makes you want to
cry because it's beautiful it's blessing
to know it makes you better so Churchill
did many things like that by the way but
this particular one he did when he was
young and you mean about war being
dangerous and all that so Churchill was
born the same the eldest son of the
junior son of a Duke and that's the
highest of the peerages and the Duke was
not rich and so you can get from a Duke
or any nobleman in England you can get
three things you can get title and you
can get money and you can get
connections and Churchill only got one
of those and the connections were
somewhat mixed but he's the sky and by
the time he was 26 years old he had
fought in three wars he had written
best-selling books about two of them he
had made himself the most highly paid
and widely read public political
journalist in
the country and then he got elected to
Parliament and also he'd written a novel
he was very energetic and then 1898 in
the Sudan the first Islamic Republic was
founded by a man named the Mahdi of
Allah his grandson runs Sudan today and
his grandson and his grand nephew are
the teachers of Osama bin Laden when
it's in Churchill fought against him and
they go down there the British the this
is Madea
the movement of the mod of the Mahdi
grew up in the desert among these
radical Islamics and they formed
themselves into a desert force and they
besieged cartoon which is down the Nile
a thousand miles from Cairo and they
took the city which was part of the
British Empire and they beheaded a
British hero by the name of Charles or
Chinese Gordon of colorful he fought a
lot of battles in China and they
beheaded him in public and the British
sent a Camel Corps down there to try to
try to relieve him and they chopped it
up this Camel Corps and it's a thousand
miles down there and much of the Nile is
impassable a long passage in the middle
two or three hundred miles you can't
take a boat down there so you can't get
stuff down there like a modern army gets
and so a guy who became very
consequential in Churchill's life was
appointed commander and what he did was
put a bunch of equipment on gum boats
and float them down to the place where
you couldn't move anymore down the Nile
and then he built a railway around the
shallow place and then he put all the
equipment on there gunboats included and
artillery and Men and regiments and he
took them by train and he put him back
in the river and he went down to
Khartoum now there's a modern army down
there and Churchill because he'd been a
best-selling author got to meet all the
famous people who knew his name anyway
and so he sits with the primary
mr. one day and he sense with he sits
with the Prince of Wales the heir to the
throne in the same week and they both
said because they want they want him to
tell them about his fighting in
Afghanistan where he fought before he
fought ends in the Sudan and there is
his book called the Malakand field force
is a best-seller and really great very
worth reading and and then when the
interview is over he says they say to
him well young man what can we do to
help you and he says to both of them to
the Prime Minister and the heir to the
throne I want to go down and fight in
the Sudan there's a force going down
there and then these days the British
Army is very officer heavy so it can
expand if there's a big war and all the
officers are besieging everybody in
authority to get to go right and so the
heir to the throne and the Prime
Minister asked the commander if they
will if he will please take Churchill
and he refuses them and so Churchill
went anyway off he went and so he gets
down there and he sees the battle and
one part of the battle was this cavalry
charge but another part of the battle
was 35,000 dervishes charged no 70,000
dervishes they were called dervish
whirling dervishes like the dust things
in the desert these Arab militant Muslim
warriors charged 25,000 British and
there's a paragraph in the book called
the river war which I encourage you to
read and young Winston Churchill who is
explicitly there to become famous and
get elected to part of it he says that
all the time to people he writes the
best-selling book the river war about
this and it's a very popular war because
everybody loved Gordon and these guys
are crazy
just like the ones we know today is what
they were like and when he writes the
story of that battle
I can remember reading it 30 years ago
and I can remember being arrested by I
went Wow look how he sees this because
here's what happened they charged across
the desert and they were simply
destroyed and the one that got the
closest to the British came within a
hundred and fifty yards and the British
lost death less than a dozen people and
the Arabs took five thousand dead and it
was because of mechanized warfare and
Churchill describes it in that in the in
one paragraph it describes it in a
chapter 13 he says they came under the
white flags the leading cavalry of the
dervishes came over the hill and they
did not understand the tragedy that
impended them because the ranges were
known and the artillery was ready and
then he starts describing the charge and
he describes it in the first half of the
paragraph from the dervish side he says
the the dust and the sweat and the
screaming and the blood and the
whistling of metal through the ranks and
then he cuts in the middle of the
paragraph to the British side and he
says the the infantry fired steadily and
stolid Lee for they were interested in
the work but eventually it became
tedious you could hardly see the
dervishes over the site but you could
tell this successively there were fewer
of them and then the men had to bring
more ammunition and others to bring
water jackets to cool the barrels so
they didn't work didn't melt so you see
he's describing a factory and that means
that by the way all this technology
we've got Churchill figured to sound say
because he was a genius just like
Lincoln and and and such man Coolidge
remember he said great statesmen are the
ambassador's Providence sent to reveal
to us our unknown selves and that means
by the way if you can find out who they
are and I can tell you
and you can read them you can know
wonderful things did they figured out
they could see so Churchill said look
we've got all this power now what are we
gonna do with it in 1925 he writes
mankind has never been in this position
before without improving the priests
ibly in virtue or enjoying wiser
guidance he has got into his hands at
last the means of his own destruction
then he sees by the way he sees the
coming of this kind of scientific
administrative government that eats half
the economy of the America of the United
States now and he says to it he says
what are they going to do you see
eventually they will manufacture us he
writes this in 1931 by the way did you
know that the family is collapsing
worldwide including in the Muslims
Muslim countries and all over America
and we're not gonna have babies right
and then we can make them and then once
we start making them can't we just make
them to do whatever we want they can be
our service just like in brave new world
by Aldous Huxley Churchill wrote that
before Huxley did you see so Churchill
understands the terror of the modern age
and we have to understand it but let me
tell you since that's very gloomy right
isn't it in 1925 that is called shall we
all commit suicide do you know whence
the Churchill wrote such a thing 15
years before he said I will say to you
as I've said to my colleagues in the
cabinet I have nothing to offer you but
blood toil tears and sweat that guy that
guy was afraid of war that's why Tom
cotton is right by the way get ready and
if you have to find it when it fast
our time grows short but I have the
method to my madness we we began with
the founding we moved to Lincoln we want
to Churchill and now I'm gonna ask for
help as I said at the beginning I get to
ask some questions of the GOP
presidential candidates in the fall so
last week I was at Stanford and I was in
the presence of the great very great
American Condoleezza Rice a child of
Birmingham or bombing ham who remembers
some quite vividly who remembers the
explosion that killed the four little
girls in Birmingham because it occurred
three blocks from her father's church
she's a very great American and I asked
her and I'm asking a lot of people what
are appropriate questions to ask
Republican presidential candidates if
you wish to find among them a Lincoln or
a Churchill not in their biography but
in their capacity to make Prudential
judgments and I asked her would it be a
fair question to ask are we safer from
the threat of a mass casualty attack of
the sort that 9/11 was today than we
were six and a half years ago she
thought that was a very fair question it
might separate candidates so now I ask
you dr. Arden what is a good question to
ask candidates to find the Lincoln's and
the Churchill's on the stage mm-hmm yeah
that's a good one and I would if I were
asking the question so you you ask
questions I'll tell you what to ask
someone I would ask them for examples of
things that the government may not do
making notes here by the way I'd give
them with you like did you know that at
Hillsdale College we now live under our
first federal government regulations and
the Department of Education and it
started in the Bush years when they have
basically given the depart of the
Department of Education control of the
private accrediting agencies and so this
week and and I remind you that I have a
really great job and I get to do
splendid things all the time but this
week I'm answering an email from the
Provost of the college David Whalen one
of the best people I know because we're
setting up our student complaint system
because we're required to have one and
we're required to make a judgment
whether a complaint from a student is a
major complaint and and we're required
to record the major complaints and we're
required to look at the complaints from
time to time and initially we're not
required to do anything about them but
we are required to to look at them and
have them available when they come every
their coming in three years to accredit
us now that's not stupid that's dog
stupid and I'll tell you the reason if
you can get in there 2,700 four-year
colleges in America and if you can get
into Hillsdale College you can get into
at least twenty six hundred and fifty of
them and that means that and and you
know as I've told you our particular
expertise is torturing the young
and and and if they don't like it they
can go somewhere else and they will and
that means that we have powerful reasons
to pay the closest attention to what
they think and do and their success
whereas the people in the Department of
Education will never know their names
right and so why should I read that
idiocy or spend any time on it but I
spend now 30 or 40 percent of my time
uncomplete a nickel from them and you go
read about the Battle of Gettysburg and
ask yourself with what the history of
the country would be different if we
didn't exist and so we are a benefit to
the nation and its government punishes
us and if you read article 1 section 8
of the Constitution there is no power
not just not to do that there's no power
to do anything like that in regard to
any one that is not how it's supposed to
work
so ask them what they cannot do it's a
great question of it now it's 8:15 and
my schedule says closing or mark so I'm
going to make mine and then I'm going to
let dr. Oren I only have two the first
begins with the question Jared how long
is your contract for
five years Joe Thomas will be retiring
Condoleezza Rice is a Cleveland Browns
fan I want you to know that part one of
my close even write my second closing
remark is that all of you can help
Hillsdale on its mission it's an
important mission you can help it with
donations but more importantly you can
help it by telling your friends about in
Primus about telling your friends about
the online courses and about telling
young people of promise no matter where
they live in this country that they
ought to give it a serious look if they
aspire to excellence they may not go
there they may go there but at least get
them to look if they wish to aspire to
Alexa lence because it's a lantern in
the north and we need more of them
and we need more of their graduates and
so thank you for being here tonight and
for supporting this College in the way
that that I just love to support it dr.
on your closing comments so I will tell
you that I've been tivoing Jared's games
for this is your fourth year fifth year
Wow he's old and it's got to the place
now and I scanned through the games and
watch him block and he's got to the
place where it's boring now nobody ever
gets around him but but I invite you to
do that I think Hugh you is a sign of
something to me is what kind of guy he
is and and all that and then that he's
part of my last point and you're part of
it too it's actually true that we're in
his bad a shape as we have been in we
may lose our Republic right but we won't
and the reason is we are going to stop
it and the reason we can this is a point
from Churchill in those gloomy things
that I told you that he wrote he makes
this point he in an essay called mass
effects and modern life in
another essay called 50-years hints they
were written about the same time he says
he says if you look at the kind of
governments it's prospering in the world
and ours is becoming like this right
because what they're doing right they
want to they want to get your education
for you they want to raise your children
for you they want to make your living
for you and then what is there for you
to do except comply right and Churchill
says that that kind of government has
been taken to its ultimate perfection by
the Bolsheviks he said which by the way
really only implements all of the social
principles that are found in the Society
of the white ant not like the bee they
can produce no honey he says like an ant
like a termite see and then he says but
human nature is more intractable than
ant nature it is at once the glory and
the safeguard of mankind that it is easy
to lead and hard to drive see by the way
that's the first principle of management
so now like Jarrod's coach I hear him
talking about Jarrad and I think he
understands that you can't make them do
it they do it it comes from them he
helps them do it he leads them to do it
in 50 years hands Churchill writes we
make all this material progress he said
imagine in 16 or 17 generations a people
who have pleasures way beyond any we
know who can live as long as they want
who can go anywhere interplanetary they
want to go what is the good of all that
how does that draw us any near the
questions that we so want to answer why
are we here and what is our life for and
the fact that we long for the answer to
those questions mean that we are not
made
to be governed against our will so you
see the good news about all this force
and power that's assembled now to cow to
cow the American people the good news is
in the end it won't work it's vulnerable
and so we have to have the wisdom to
understand that and we have to have the
courage to fight it thank you and good
night